bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir est
l'un des meilleurs spécialistes de la
géopolitique contemporaine bonsoir
Thomas Goma merci d'être avec nous
historiens directeur de literie vous
signez chez Taillandier les ambitions
inavoués que préparent les grandes
puissances Chinese Russie iraniens Inde
aussi États-Unis vous inversez la
perspective en vous plaçant du point de
vue de nos adversaires ou de nos
partenaires on va en parler et ça nous
permet d'en finir avec un biais bien
français le nombrilisme stratégique ça
mérite une explication on en parle
ensemble tout à l'heure mais on commence
ce soir avec les retraites bien sûr ce
mardi noir pour l'exécutif les syndicats
jouer leur atout sur la réforme le pays
a fonctionné au ralenti un peu partout
en France on va y revenir c'était la
sixième journée d'action très suivie à
Paris on va faire le point sur les
chiffres alors étant entrer dans une
nouvelle phase du conflit le
gouvernement peut-il rester sourd à la
rue grand débat dans un instant avec nos
invités sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris et puis Bourbon Express une
histoire de bras d'honneur ce soir à
l'Assemblée vous verrez tout cela enfin
vous regardez
[Musique]
ils avaient promis un pays à l'arrêt
avec des cortèges partout en France on
va faire le point dans le détail sur les
manifestations et les secteurs en grève
transport éducation EDF raffinerie
routier lycéens les syndicats ont
clairement changé de braquet en décidant
de durcir le mouvement bonsoir Antoine
Armands et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes député renaissance de Haute-Savoie
vous nous direz quel bilan vous tirez de
cette nouvelle manifestation
démonstration de force bonsoir Elsa
faussillon et merci d'être là vous êtes
député communiste des Hauts-de-Seine
dans le cortège parisien aujourd'hui
évidemment tout comme vous j'imagine
Fabienne tato oui bonsoir vous en sortez
à peine secrétaire national des
ingénieurs cadres et techniciens de la
CGT enfin bonsoir pierre Ferracci ravi
de vous accueillir sur ce plateau vous
êtes présidé le groupe Alpha c'est un
groupe d'expertise et de conseils aux
entreprises et vous êtes un grand
connaisseur du monde syndical Thomas
gaumart c'est un sujet bien français que
nos retraites mais je suis sûr que il
dépasse aussi nos frontières et votre
regard nous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
intervenir alors avant de débattre on
plante le décor comme chaque soir avec
le billet de Stéphane blackovski combien
où et qui a défilé contre la réforme
aujourd'hui le chrono de Blacko c'est
parti
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam et je me
retourne comme chaque soir pour vous
accueillir alors les chiffres 700000
personnes à Paris selon la CGT
81000 selon le ministère de l'Intérieur
cgtraction pas d'accord sur les chips ça
me surprend énormément mais en tout cas
côté syndicat ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que dès ce midi avant même le
départ de la manifestation parisienne du
cortège parisien on parlait d'un succès
incontestable plus 20% en gros de
mobilisation des ailes en berger on n'a
pas les chiffres nationaux mais dans les
préfectures on confirme que dans pas mal
de villes de provinces la mobilisation a
un peu ou beaucoup augmenté donc
satisfaction à la CFDT notamment
cette colère la colère sociale la colère
du monde du travail fasse une réforme
injuste il est toujours aussi puissante
et elle se manifeste aujourd'hui de
façon encore plus puissante dans dans la
rue moi je crois pouvoir dire que
aujourd'hui on a une mobilisation qui
est historique au regard des 40 ou 50
dernières années en terme de nombre de
personnes mobilisées donc pour la
mobilisation c'est gagné mais je vous
rappelle que le mot d'ordre de cette 6e
journée de mobilisation il était c'est
de le Titre 1 du communiqué de
l'intersyndicale regardez sous les logos
mettons la France à l'arrêt bon si on
prend l'expression au pied de la lettre
la France n'était pas totalement à
l'arrêt aujourd'hui il y a eu un bon
coup de frein c'est sur sur l'activité
économique on peut regarder les chiffres
officiels qui bien sûr vont être
contestés mais là c'est en noir la
manifestation du 19 janvier 19 et
janvier donc la première mobilisation
puis en rouge celle d'aujourd'hui vous
voyez que même si c'est très serré on
officiellement le taux de grévistes est
un peu en baisse même si on conteste les
chiffres ce que reconnaissent les
syndicats c'est que c'est malgré tout
avec l'inflation en ce moment assez
difficile pour une partie des salariés
de ce sacrifier un jour de salaire
encore plus plusieurs jours de salaire
donc c'est évidemment pas facile de
mettre la France à l'arrêt si les
salariés sont pas bien décidés à faire
grève cela dit il y a quand même de
nouvelles catégories qui sont entrées
dans le mouvement et ça peut changer les
choses là je vous ai mis une photo hop
un petit peu pixelisé mais c'est manif à
Charles de Gaulle pour dire que les
aéroports étaient en grève 20 à 30% de
vols annulée sur l'ensemble de la France
les éboueurs à Paris les routiers on
commence à se mobiliser alors ça quand
les routiers commencent à stabiliser ça
commence à sentir le gros gros coup de
frein si en plus on ajoute les grèves
reconductibles à EDF la SNCF et puis
alors bien sûr le blocage de raffinerie
qui ne vient que de commencer dans un
datant peut-être d'autres effets il y a
vraiment de quoi mettre la France à
l'arrêt donc le gouvernement enfin
j'imagine devrait s'inquiéter mais il y
a quand même un chiffre dans les
sondages qui peut le rassurer enfin je
sais pas lui donner de l'espoir bon le
chiffre des sondages aussi toujours
celui-ci voilà deux tiers des Français
sont contre la réforme des retrait mais
il y a un autre chiffre dans le même
sondage c'est Harry c'est interactive
qui nous dit en fait il a encore plus
qui pensent que finalement la réforme va
être adoptée par le Parlement donc
peut-être que le gouvernement se dit que
la résignation l'emporterait finalement
sur la colère en tout cas c'est que ce
qui est sûr c'est que le gouvernement on
l'a appris veut faire voter au plus vite
cette réforme dès la semaine prochaine
vous allez pouvoir nous donner le
calendrier tout à l'heure et on se dit
dès lors que la réforme est adoptée au
Parlement est-ce que la CFDT qui n'est
pas un syndicat révolutionnaire irait
contre une mesure votée par la présente
ma nationale je ne sais pas les 10 jours
à venir vont donc être décisif dans ce
bras de fer syndicat Parlement
l'interfall serait ni en ce moment donc
ils vont décider des mobilisations on ne
sait pas encore exactement mais en tout
cas les plus motivés pour durcir le
mouvement c'est la CGT on écoute
Philippe Martinez pardon ça fait un
petit moment que la CGT le dit qu'il
faut passer à la vitesse supérieure
après cinq journées de mobilisation très
importante comme il y a pas de réponse
du gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est une
nouvelle étape avec la plus grosse
mobilisation depuis le début et puis des
grèves qui vont se
généralisée dans beaucoup d'endroits
donc vous venez de le souffler la CGT
dit 3 millions et demi de manifestations
de manifestants pardon aujourd'hui en
France ce qu'annonce la CGT mais ce
qu'on sent bien venir c'est qu'il va y
avoir un durcissement du mouvement
est-ce que c'est FDT et CGT vont être
sur la même ligne dès lors que le
mouvement se durcisse que le
gouvernement peut jouer là-dessus alors
il y a un proverbe c'est divisé pour
mieux régner donc je me suis renseigné
c'est incroyable qui date du 4e siècle
avant Jésus-Christ bah ça fait 25 siècle
qu'on dit que diviser pour mieux régner
ça peut être un argument peut-être que
le gouvernement est au courant je sais
pas merci beaucoup Stéphane alors
Antoine Armand vous qui êtes député qui
portez cette réforme c'est la sixième
journée d'action très suivie même si on
va discuter des grévistes comment vous
accueillez cette nouvelle opposition
dans la rue d'abord je pense qu'il faut
quand même saluer le calme dans lequel
ce sont en globalité il y a eu quelques
quelques échauffourés dérouler les
manifestants et saluer d'abord les
forces de l'ordre qui ont permis cela et
surtout la grande qualité de
l'encadrement et la possibilité avec les
manifestations se déroulent dans le
calme c'est le socle de notre démocratie
sociale c'est extrêmement
féliciter les syndicats je suis juste
content de voir qu'en France les
manifestations peuvent se dérouler d'une
manière extrêmement sereine et c'est
important les organisateurs
c'est juste que j'ai pas félicité des
syndicats ou à leur donner des bons des
mauvais points c'est pas c'est pas mon
rôle ensuite moi ce que je constate
c'est que aujourd'hui et probablement
dans quelques heures le Sénat après
l'Assemblée nationale qui aurait bien
aimé le faire si j'allais dire toutes
les oppositions avaient fait comme le
Parti communiste c'est-à-dire avait
retiré leur amendements pour qu'on
puisse en arriver aux articles clés le
Sénat est en train d'examiner les
articles clés de ce projet sur le recul
de l'âge à 71 donc les sénateurs la
représentation nationale est en train de
travailler les élus au suffrage
universel indirect après les élus
régionales sont en train de travailler
cette loi de l'examiner de la modifier
donc j'entends prends en compte la
légitimité de la rue elle est importante
elle est audible mais la légitimité de
la représentation nationale dans une
démocratie parlementaire et j'espère ne
pas avoir à le rappeler elle prime elle
prime donc pour vous elle est supérieure
à la légitimité du droit de grève
le droit de grève il est totalement
légitimité
sur l'autre non mais la loi est votée
par le Parlement alors elle est pas
encore votée et on verra ce qui va et en
particulier Elsa faussillon clairement
on sent qu'on est rentré dans une
deuxième phase du mouvement la CGT
clairement on a entendu Philippe
Martinez avec cette expression passer à
la vitesse supérieure ça veut dire
forcément plus de blocage ça veut dire
aussi plus de galère pour les Français
vous soutenez ça
d'abord la galère c'est d'abord ce que
nous propose le gouvernement en
travaillant deux ans de plus et je crois
que les citoyens de ce pays les
travailleurs de ce pays l'ont bien
compris le rejettent très massivement ça
crée une unité très forte dans le pays
j'ai toutes les catégories d'actifs
d'ailleurs il faut voir combien cette
réforme est rejetée que ce soit pour
ceux et celles qui ont des métiers très
pénibles mais aussi pour d'autres qui
ont des conditions d'emplois parfois
plus favorables qui contestent aussi
très majoritaire cette réforme oui je
pense qu'on est un tournant d'abord par
les chiffres extrêmement importants de
mobilisation oui ce sont des
mobilisations historiques historiques
par le nombre historique aussi par tous
ces lieux qui se démultiplient de
manifestations dans le pays que ce soit
dans les très grandes villes mais aussi
dans la ruralité ou dans des plus
petites villes chacun
prend en charge son territoire et
organise des manifestations et c'est
extrêmement fort de voir ça pour égayer
cette bataille il va falloir durcir
c'est que aujourd'hui il y a dans la
population certes des gens qui pensent
que ça va être voté au Parlement mais
aussi une majorité qui soutient la
mobilisation et une partie de ces
soutiens qui ne participent pas encore à
la mobilisation moi je leur fais un
appel et je pense que les syndicats vont
le faire aussi participer à cette
mobilisation nous pouvons la gagner si
vous y participez également la question
du blocage et de l'arrêt elles ne sont
qu'un outil un moyen de se faire
entendre de ce goût
légitimement qui jusqu'à lors
multiplie élémentçons j'ai les
provocations et qui fait énormément et
légitimement monter la colère dans ce
pays donc il y a une solution pour le
gouvernement c'est de renoncer d'autant
que le texte qui est en train d'être
voté au Parlement va enlever
toute justification à faire la réforme
quand elle va finir par coûter plus cher
alors on va y venir dans le détail on va
y venir justement au jour à venir on
comprend bien qu'on rentre dans une
période décisive je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder qui était dans les
cortèges on parle de la Genèse on parle
du privé aussi et puis de l'entrée de
des routiers parmi les grévistes je vous
redonne la parole juste après mais
d'abord cortège parisien signe Clément
Perrot
sixième journée de mobilisation depuis
le début du mouvement et dans les
cortèges une impression unanime les
messages ont beau être répétés de manif
en manif le gouvernement n'est pas à
l'écoute je pense que c'est du mépris
parce que vous voyez on est assez
nombreux et il y a pas vraiment de
réponse
peut faire vraiment des personnes qui
sont droites dans leur bottes un
gouvernement qui n'écoutent pas qui
n'écoute toujours pas mais nous nous
serons toujours là pour pour créer bien
fort j'ai l'impression de crier dans le
désert
c'est terrible j'espère que au bout d'un
moment le gouvernement va prendre
conscience qu'en quand il y a autant de
gens dans la rue autant de jours ça
signifie quand même quelque chose
durcir le mouvement c'est ce que
préconise désormais de nombreux
manifestants mettre l'économie française
à l'arrêt serait le seul moyen d'être
enfin entendu le gaz le DF les
raffineries l'éducation tout ça vous
bloquez le pays comme en 95
historiquement il y avait jamais que ça
qui a fonctionné c'est le blocage du
pays donc oui ça engendre des
difficultés mineurs sur le moment mais
c'est nécessaire parce que les 15
minutes qu'on perd à attendre le métro
c'est deux ans qu'on gagne derrière on
peut arriver à mettre à
à genoux l'économie et montrer que cette
réforme n'a pas lieu d'être le
risque quel type d'action plus dur moi
j'entends parler de sabotage et très
honnêtement j'ai pas envie qu'on a qu'on
en arrive là le ton se durcit la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas difficile
pour le gouvernement de miser
aujourd'hui sur un essoufflement de la
contestation
votre réaction aux mots qu'on entend des
manifestants maître le péage nous c'est
une expression qui a été utilisée par un
syndicaliste de la CGT est-ce que la CGT
en train de changer de stratégie est-ce
que vous voulez très clairement
maintenant faire en sorte de
désorganiser le pays bon d'abord il faut
rappeler que c'est on est à la sixième
journée de mobilisation
des mobilisations qui à chaque fois ont
drainé des participants des manifestants
très variés par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
rencontrer aussi auparavant beaucoup
plus de jeunes d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus de jeunes la présence des
femmes qu'ont bien compris que cette
réforme pourrait elles allaient payer
cher notamment elle
et puis une grande diversité de
mais jusqu'à présent CFDT CGT parler
d'une seule voix et la stratégie était
claire c'était au fond ne pas trop
enquiquiner les français tout en se
faisant entendre oui avec la volonté
d'ailleurs de laisser passer les
vacances à cette stratégie quand on est
syndicaliste et qu'on choisit une date
pareille en disant on laisse passer les
vacances et on manifeste au retour là on
a l'impression que c'est terminé ce
temps-là est-ce qu'on se trompe en
disant ça ce qu'on entend dans les
manifestants ce qu'on entend dire c'est
un gouvernement droit dans ses bottes
j'ai l'impression de prêcher dans un
désert donc nous en tant que syndicat et
dans notre inter syndical qui est très
soudée on a exprimé de manière
effectivement très
responsable notre attente en tant que
salarié en tant que citoyen et on est
face à un gouvernement qui ne veut
absolument pas entendre cette
mobilisation et ces demandes là et qui
ne veut pas renoncer pour l'instant ça
réforme
une fois aucun caractère du point de vue
financière et alors même qu'il y a une
véritable urgence sociale concernant les
salaires on est à la veille du 8 mars
concernant l'égalité
salariale et professionnelle et puis
l'urgence climatique dont je trouve
qu'on ne parle pas assez et qui est
vraiment un moteur aussi de mobilisation
pour la jeunesse moi je le ressens très
fortement ça donc Paris gagner pour les
syndicats aujourd'hui même si un peu
moins de grévistes aujourd'hui on a eu
une très très belle mobilisation on va
peut-être atteindre les 3 millions de de
manifestants au niveau 1 dit déjà
de l'Intérieur vient de tomber au niveau
national 1,2 millions de magnési en tout
cas une une mobilisation très très
réussie aujourd'hui
en termes de diversité aussi de lieu de
de manifestation on recense plus de 300
millions de manifestations moi j'ai j'ai
des remontées qui disent c'est la
première fois qu'on manifeste dans ma
ville on a des manifestations de plus en
plus fortes vraiment un très beau succès
oui pierre ferrachi on termine ce tour
de table quel regard déjà vous porter
sur cette nouvelle journée quel bilan
vous tirez ce soir et est-ce que vous
pensez que l'unité syndicale qui a été
exemplaire si j'étais CFDT jusqu'à
présent peut tenir dans la durée la
journée d'aujourd'hui c'est un
incontestable succès c'est pas la peine
d'ergoter sur les chiffres il y a plus
de manifestants que la dernière fois
qu'au plus haut de la du mouvement
ministère de l'Intérieur un million
200000 c'est à peu près le chiffre de la
précédente j'espère que le ministre
d'armanin va être plus précis dans les
chiffres qui ne l'était dans la crise du
Stade de France au moment de la finale
de la Ligue des Champions
moi moi j'aimerais qu'on focalise
effectivement comme vous le proposez sur
l'unité syndicale plutôt que sur les
propos parfois un peu excessifs des uns
et des autres on peut prendre aussi ceux
d'Olivier Véran qui faisait un lien
entre la France à l'arrêt et puis la
catastrophe écologique sanitaire et
alimentaire
il a tenu ses propos Olivier du socle
qui trouvait que c'était une réforme de
gauche et qu'il n'y avait pas de perdant
bon il va falloir démontrer à ceux qui
vont travailler un peu plus longtemps
qui ne sont pas perdants dans la réforme
durer ce qui n'empêche pas des
divergences sur les modalités d'action
mais elles existent Philippe artisan et
Laurent Berger le disait d'ailleurs il y
a quelques jours l'un et l'autre elles
existent depuis le début donc c'est vrai
que quand il y a une forme d'immobilisme
du côté gouvernemental on a tendance à
réfléchir à des moyens plus radicaux ils
pensaient qu'elle va perdurer parce que
ils vont tous en berger va céder à de
nouvelles stratégie de la CGT et
accepter les blocages je pense qu'ils
vont tout faire pour la faire perdurer
après je sais pas si l'un va céder à
l'autre ça se pose pas en ces termes là
depuis au début du conflit on dit
d'ailleurs que c'est Laurent Berger qui
conduit le mouvement parce qu'il est le
leader de la première organisation
syndicale maintenant on va dire qu'il va
céder à Philippe Martinez une question
je pense que le gouvernement devrait
apporter une attention très forte au
fait que pour la première fois depuis
longtemps 8 syndicats sont totalement
Unis si on ne revendications qui est
très clair qui porte sur l'âge légal et
moi je ne laisserai pas dire que il y a
urgence sur le plan financier il y a
nécessiteur rétablir les équilibres
personne ne le ni d'ailleurs y compris
sur le plan syndical il y a simplement
d'autres méthodes qui sont proposées que
celles qui est qui est avancée par le
gouvernement et ce qui est un peu
dommage c'est que le débat ne soit pas
ouvert depuis le début toutes les
fenêtres sont fermées après je
reviendrai sur le fait que cette réforme
a été mal préparée il y a une vraie
crise du travail en France moi je ne
laisserai pas dire là aussi que les
Français veulent plus travailler ils
veulent travailler autrement il y a un
problème de sens au travail il y a un
problème de conditions de travail je
répète souvent que en Finlande quand ils
ont d'ailleurs décalé de deux ans l'âge
de la retraite ils ont demandé au
partenaire sociaux pendant 5 ans de
travailler sur le travail et notamment
sur le travail des Sen sur la charge de
travail sur le pouvoir d'achat des
seniors sur leur fans de carrière
professionnelle on n'a pas fait ça on le
paye aujourd'hui et je crois quelqu'un
disait en avril 2019 au moment du grand
débat que si on déporte l'âge légal sans
s'occuper effectivement du taux d'emploi
des seniors on a tout faux
vous êtes un peu seul contre tous sur ce
plateau mais ça représente aussi bien
voilà les les différents comptes
politiques et on l'a vu dans les c'est
quand même dans les militaires il manque
les républicains
deux choses
sur la méthode et sur le fond sur la
méthode ce qu'on vient de nous dire à
mot feutrer les modalités d'action le
besoin d'aller plus loin c'est en fait
un chantage au blocage du pays comme on
le constate dans les raffineries des
gens qui utilisent leur métier pour
bloquer les services publics et l'action
quotidienne des Français chacun est
libre d'apprécier moi j'appelle ça du
chantage social sur le fond
parce que je voudrais informer qu'il
nous regarde des mots qui ont été
employés qui font polémiques depuis
quelques jours Emmanuel Lépine de la CGT
ils sont tous à la CGT si la question
est de mettre le péage nous l'économie à
genoux la réponse est oui Sébastien
Ménétrier CGT mine qui promet une
semaine noire dans son secteur avec
coupure d'électricité ciblée
blocage qui ont déjà eu lieu des sites
stratégiques comme les raffineries de
pétrole et puis enfin Olivier matheux
qui lui a carrément menacé de mettre le
feu donc pour vous tout ça comment dire
quoi représentatif au bras de fer
cervicales
qui a été perdue des élections
législatives qui ont été perdus un débat
au Parlement à l'Assemblée nationale qui
a été escamotée et un débat au Sénat qui
est en train de tourner au désavantage
des opposants à réforme et maintenant
les manifestations ont lieu on passe à
un chantage au blocage et je voudrais
quand même dire quelque chose quelque
chose qu'on aille aujourd'hui couper
l'électricité dans la commune d'Annonay
sous prétexte que le ministre du Travail
en a été le lait c'est quand même le
comble à la fois de la fantaisie pour
être sympathique mais du chantage social
pour être réaliste donc je crois qu'il
faudrait quand même sérieusement qu'à un
moment les organisations syndicales qui
ont le mérite d'organiser des
manifestations dans le calme celui des
Solidaris clairement des attaques des
chantages des blocages sur les coupures
d'électricité chez Olivier du soft 2018
du travail c'est la CGT là qui est
pointé moi je pense que le gouvernement
dans sa méthode et dans sa stratégie
pousse les salariés
vraiment à l'épuisement donc vous
soutenez les coupures vous soutenez les
coupures c'est ça que vous nous dites je
préfère déjà parler sans être interrompu
s'il vous plaît merci
on utilise des moyens qui sont à notre
disposition et dans un pays quand on a
des salariés qui s'expriment
également par le biais du dialogue
social auquel vous appelez tous de vos
vœux mais qu'on n'entend rien qu'on ne
bouge pas d'un iota et qu'on propose une
réforme qui est contraire à l'intérêt
des salariés qui va très majoritairement
à l'encontre de l'opinion publique à un
moment donné il faut savoir écouter il
faut réouvrir le dialogue et se remettre
autour d'une table vous le refusez
absolument alors nous en tant que
salarié on emploie les moyens qui sont à
notre disposition on utilise notre outil
de travail et on fait ce qu'on a à faire
vous soyez en situation d'écoute alors
on va essayer de voir s'il y a du grain
à moudre ou pas sur quoi ça pourrait
bouger ou pas Thomas gobart votre regard
nous intéresse quand même parce que même
si c'est un débat très franco-français
d'autres pays nous regardent on est dans
un énième dialogue de sourd à la
française classique ou ses différences
cette fois-ci
moi ça me rappelle d'ailleurs ça a été
rappelé dans le dans le reportage ça me
rappelle beaucoup 1995 dans la dans le
dans le discours je me sens un peu
effectivement pas tellement à ma place
pour arbitrer parce que je suis très
loin de mes préoccupations mais ce qui
me frappe néanmoins c'est le contraste
entre cette manifestation telle qu'elle
est présentée très bien organisée et je
sais pas quel terme utiliser pour
blesser personne mais la cacophonie
auquel assistait au Parlement à
l'Assemblée nationale pour tout dire
assez triste vu de l'extérieur pour le
citoyen que que je suis après si on
cherche à remettre ça dans un cadre plus
large au niveau européen on constate
évidemment en allongement de la durée de
la vie c'est c'est une très bonne chose
en soi et un allongement du temps de
travail l'exemple je trouve que vous
prenez de la Finlande est très
intéressant c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il y a eu cette
allongement qui a été préparé par un
dialogue social mais fondamentalement il
y a quand même une tendance à la
convergence du modèle européen et je
pense qu'il faut essayer de le voir à la
fois au niveau entre européen et puis au
niveau global c'est à dire qu'au niveau
global ce qui se passe fondamentalement
rétrécissement de l'Europe un
vieillissement et une perte de
compétitivité de l'Europe par rapport
aux autres grandes zones que sont
évidemment l'Asie du Sud-Est les
États-Unis le tout dans un contexte où
l'inflation frappe en premier lieu
aujourd'hui les Européens et donc je
pense qu'il faut remettre ça
effectivement dans un cadre et puis je
finirai en disant effectivement je pense
que si la réflexion sur le travail est
assez absente c'est-à-dire que à-t-on
bien compris qu'on est dans une économie
qui est de plus en plus une économie de
services de moins en moins une économie
industrielle et ça c'est très
problématique par rapport aux formes de
représentation qui accompagnent ces
mouvements et je pense que tout ça va
être très percuté par le choc
technologique l'intelligence
artificielle donc peut-être aussi
essayer de déplacer un peu le débat sur
la suite du travail et la manière dont
ce travail va évoluer dans les décennies
à venir ensuite Antoine Armand
au fond il fallut mettre cette réforme
le cas d'une grande réflexion plus vaste
sur le travail par rapport à ces
transformations à la fois dans notre
pays en Europe mais aussi dans le monde
et ça ça a manqué je crois que vous êtes
d'accord avec avec ce constat-là tous
bah on les en tout cas très clairement
le gouvernement Macron précédent
l'actuel mais je pourrais citer des
gouvernements précédents plutôt fait du
mal aux conditions de travail au sens au
travail dans un système du tout profit
ou faut dégager des marges au détriment
de à la fois la rémunération du travail
mais aussi des conditions de travail
avec les retraites on est on est au cœur
quand même la question de ce qu'on fait
de la valeur ajoutée est-ce qu'elle va
vers le capital dans les poches des
actionnaires est-ce qu'elle rémunère le
travail combien qui décide aussi est-ce
que les salariés ont un pouvoir pour
pour décider et les retraites en fait
c'est un effet un peu ça cumule tout
toutes ces questions donc les gens qui
manifestent ils manifestent à la fois
pour la question de la retraite ils
disent on veut pas travailler deux ans
de plus mais pouvez pas travailler deux
ans de plus en plus dans ces conditions
là avec des boulots ou aujourd'hui les
conditions peuvent être plus ou moins
difficiles mais aussi le sens l'éthique
au travail ça va arriver
il y a un texte de loi qui va arriver
dans deux mois sur le travail
précisément sur la question des droits
familiaux sur la place du travail dans
la société pourquoi il arrive après la
réforme je suis quand même obligé de
corriger un point vous avez
collectivement laissé entendre qui ne se
serait rien passé depuis 5 ans je me
permets quand même de dire que nous
avons le taux de chômage en France le
plus bas depuis 20 ans on était il y a
encore quelques années vous étiez sur
ces plateaux vous parliez du fléau du
chômage de France de demain en France on
est en train d'en sortir la première
qualité du marché du travail c'est de ne
pas créer du chômage donc on peut quand
même s'en réjouir collectivement est-ce
qu'on porte une vision du travail bien
sûr on porte une vision de l'égalité
professionnelle quand on met en place
l'index égalité homme-femme non il ne
marche pas il mesure il est fait pour
corriger et il y aura également
c'est pour ça que vous le remettez en
place pour l'index on reste sur notre
sujet et on a réformé l'assurance on est
en train on a réformé et on continue à
réformer l'assurance chômage on a
réformé notre système d'apprentissage
pour que l'insertion sur le marché du
travail et que l'ascension sociale soit
possible donc la vision globale du
travail on l'apporte et c'est sûrement
pas des personnes qui étaient au
gouvernement qui ont contribué à
l'explosion du chômage de masse pendant
30 ans qui vont venir nous donner des
leçons sur le travail
n'arrive pas à vous comprendre
du marché du travail et vous avez raison
collectivement de dire qu'on a besoin de
donner du sens au travail et d'améliorer
les conditions de vie au travail et
c'est le sens du projet qui sera
présenté au printemps prochain
d'abord soyez pas trop caricatural parce
que je ne suis pas là en tant que
syndicaliste non mais vous avez une CGT
partie communiste et un syndicaliste ok
non j'ai pas dit moi le travail je le
vis au quotidien dans les entreprises
dans les collectivités locales et auprès
des représentants du personnel puisque
c'est une de nos spécialités je pense
que vous n'avez pas tout fait bien sur
le travail moi j'ai eu un regard très
critique sur les ordonnances
les syndicats seront pas tout à fait
d'accord avec moi là-dessus je pense que
les 35 heures telles qu'elles ont été
appliquées de façon très égalitaire ont
amené les entreprises à relever
massivement la productivité et
l'intensification du travail et ça fait
beaucoup de dégâts sur le terrain des
conditions de travail pour un certain
nombre de salarié notamment dans les TPE
et dans les PME donc là
mais qui n'ont pas été traités avant
on a beaucoup dit que les corps
intermédiaires n'étaient pas au fond
tasse de thé du président de la
République et qu'il avait d'entrer de
jeu au fond un peu balayé les syndicats
est-ce qu'ils ne le payent pas
aujourd'hui moi je vais pas vous parler
de T je vais vous parler de démocratie
sociale ça fait 25-30 ans enfin les
personnes qui sont encore plus
compétentes que moi sur le sujet
pourront le dire qu'on a une
affaiblissement de la démocratie sociale
qui se traduit notamment par la
participation aux élections
professionnelles qui est quand même un
marqueur une température extrêmement
importante autant que celle aux
élections politiques sur les lois non
mais bien sûr absolument mais c'est une
crise de démocratique plus générale
malheureusement qu'on vit la
sur ce point on a donné la possibilité à
ce qui est désaccords de branche et
d'entreprise c'est un plus pour le
marqueur je voudrais revenir sur un
point que vous avez mentionné parce que
il me paraît très important il y a eu
récemment un accord entre les
partenaires sociaux sur la participation
sur le partage de la valeur à mon sens
on peut et on doit aller plus loin ce
que je trouve particulièrement
intéressant et important dans ce que
vous avez dit c'est que à mon sens et à
nouveau je m'exprime ma petite
personnelle cette augmentation enfin
cette redistribution par le partage de
la valeur il faut absolument qu'on
l'associe à une réflexion sur la
gouvernance en entreprise parce que ce
qu'on constate dans différents pays les
pays scandinaves ou l'Allemagne c'est
que quand on a une cogestion c'est le
cas de l'Allemagne en tout cas il faut
que ça prenne une forme qui correspond à
notre culture française quand on a une
plus grande participation au sein de
l'entreprise les intérêts sont davantage
propriétés après la retraite c'est
intéressant de voir qu'il y a beaucoup
un grand volet de travail qui attend je
vous ramène au texte retraite parce que
on entre dans une course contre la
montre cette semaine bon soir Marco
pommier vous êtes seul des quatre
colonnes à l'Assemblée vous allez nous
expliquer précisément ce qui va se
passer maintenant on l'a dit le texte
est en discussion Sénat l'article 7 le
coeur de la forme de la réforme et
discuter il devrait être adopté d'ici la
fin de semaine et après il y a plusieurs
scénarii possibles au Parlement
oui Myriam après le Sénat ou la réforme
des retraites a de grandes chances
d'être adoptée d'ici dimanche minuit et
bien la prochaine étape ce sera mercredi
prochain pour la commission mixte
paritaire la fameuse CMP 1 huis clos
composé de 7 députés et de 7 sénateurs
ils vont tenter de se mettre d'accord
sur un texte commun une CMP dans
laquelle et bien les partisans de la
réforme sont vraisemblablement
majoritaires en cas d'accord à
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
devront se prononcer sur ce texte de
conciliation un vote final prévu jeudi
prochain le 16 mars à l'Assemblée et si
le vote n'est pas favorable alors Marco
que se passe-t-il si les députés aussi
et les sénateurs ne trouvent pas
d'accord en commission mixte paritaire
et bien Myriam on sera reparti pour un
tour l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
devront recommencer à examiner le texte
avec à la toute fin une ultime lecture à
l'Assemblée qui aura le dernier mot quoi
qu'il arrive tout cela ira très vite pas
plus de 10 jours pourquoi et bien parce
que vous le savez le Parlement a
jusqu'au 26 mars pour examiner cette
réforme des retraites à cette date si le
Parlement ne s'est pas prononcé sur le
texte et bien le gouvernement pourra
décider de mettre en oeuvre sa réforme
par ordonnance et puis Myriam il faut
bien avoir en tête que s'il estime
nécessaire le gouvernement peut aussi à
tout moment recourir au 49-3 pour faire
passer cette réforme des retraites si
controversées merci beaucoup Marco
pommier Elsa faucillon comment vous
voyez la semaine qui s'ouvre commission
mix paritaire il devrait y avoir
probablement un accord tel que on le
comprend avec l'opposition au Sénat
puisque c'est la droite
le vote vous le respecterez si la
réforme est adoptée
je me dis quand même à ce celles qui
nous écoutent que le 47 ans est un choix
qui n'avait pas lieu d'être c'est à dire
que passer par budgétaire qui
normalement doit être votée au 31
décembre mais là c'est un texte
rectificatif aucun besoin de passer par
ce 47 ans à part la volonté du
gouvernement de réduire et avoir de
réduire le débat dans l'hémicycle ils
prennent une réunion de CMP
moi je fais pas de politique fiction
parce que je remarque quand même que
dans un Parlement il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses en simplement
quelques heures donc pas de politique
fiction je vois que la droite
sénatoriale en tout cas et cherche
évidemment le deal avec avec le
gouvernement il faudra quand même
regarder je vous le disais tout à
l'heure mais plus on regarde les
amendements qui vont être adoptés par le
Sénat et plus ça va renforcer l'idée que
c'est un texte qui n'a aucune assise
budgétaire c'est à dire récompensation
financière
importante que ce que le gouvernement
voulait disait vouloir économiser on va
arriver à la même chose donc franchement
c'est une grosse responsabilité pour les
sénateurs de droite d'accepter ce dit là
eux qui depuis des années nous explique
en coeur avec les libéraux qu'il faut
compresser les dépenses publiques et qui
dans le même temps font des transferts
au privé de manière hyper conséquente je
trouve que c'est
en garde
globalement
vous aurez le mot de la fin gare
qui viendrait au fond et bien voilà
grignoter les économies nécessaires par
cette je suis ravi je constate qu'en fin
les oppositions que constate réalise
qu'il y a dans ce texte des vrais
avancées sociales qui certes coûtent de
l'argent par rapport à l'économie mais
qui écoute essayez précisément parce
qu'il y a des compensations
et majoritaire dans la commission mixte
paritaire donc il doit pas se passer
grand chose
parlementaire vous vous en doutez bien
évidemment semaine décisive on verra ce
qui se passe dans la rue si le pays va
être bloqué si l'opinion ou pas va se
retourner il reste encore beaucoup à
dire merci beaucoup d'être venu débattre
sur le plateau de LCP vous restez avec
moi Thomas goba dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir le regard européen de
Richard Verdi sur le mouvement social
français l'économie avec Fanny guinochet
qui va revenir sur le panier
anti-inflation annoncé par Bercy et puis
Bourbon Express elles amont d'un Gava
une histoire de bras d'honneur à
l'Assemblée vous allez tout nous
expliquer mais d'abord on va plonger
dans votre livre Thomas gaumard le monde
est de plus en plus incertain de plus en
plus inquiétants on a besoin de votre
grille de lecture sur les ambitions
inavouées des grandes puissances qui
nous ont tout regardé c'est dans
l'invitation signer m'a été vraiment
si on vous invite Thomas gomard c'est
pour nous parler des ambitions inavouées
des grandes puissances titre de votre
nouvelle essaie 325 pages pour
comprendre les stratégies de demain de 9
pays en jeu qui forcément ont un impact
pour la France car l'objectif est bien
là repenser nos priorités à long terme
en rompant dites-vous avec notre
nombrilisme stratégique on a tendance à
regarder le monde uniquement à travers
nos problèmes nos capacités nos
incapacités alors que je pense que ce
qui est intéressant quand on fait des
relations internationales c'est
d'essayer d'inverser la perspective et
de se poser la première question qui
devrait être au fond ce que les autres
pensent de nous et ce qu'ils font
commencent à délimite ce qu'on peut
faire Thomas Gomart vous êtes historiens
directeur de literie l'Institut français
des relations internationales et vous
êtes l'un des meilleurs spécialistes sur
la géopolitique les rapports
entre-puissances vous passionnent thème
déjà exploré dans précédents ouvrages à
l'aune de la guerre en Ukraine de la
nouvelle donne énergétique et des
risques climatiques vous analysez 9 pays
classés en trois catégories les pays à
la forte assise continentale les pays
qui exercent leur influence sur l'espace
maritime et enfin ces pays où la
religion jouent un rôle près dominant et
à chaque fin de chapitre vous en tirez
des enseignements pour la France vous
donnez des clés pour nous aider à
comprendre comment l'histoire un mot de
lait chaque État et un flux sur la
vision du monde de leur dirigeants
aujourd'hui pourquoi si Jean Ping
veut-il redessiner l'Eurasie à sa main
comment l’allemagne va-t-elle bâtir ses
nouvelles relations avec Washington
Pékin ou encore Moscou après la guerre
en Ukraine comment le refus de la
démocratie et de la haine de l'Occident
motivent-il la Russie dans son désir de
rétablir un empire éclaté en 1991 la
surprise stratégique n'est pas
l'agression russe mais le niveau de
résistance des ukrainien qui au fond
nous interroge indirectement par leur
cohésion nationale sur notre propre
cohésion nationale question qui se pose
à mon sens pour tous les pays européens
et qui est le sujet majeur qui doit nous
occuper dans les années à venir alors
une question ce soir Thomas gaumart que
pèse encore la France dans ce nouvel
ordre mondial totalement bouleversé
réponse Thomas Goma elle pèse qu'elle a
envie de peser en fait c'est à dire que
on a une impression peut-être de
réduction mais en réalité quand on
regarde les choses en perspective
historique on a aussi des possibilités
d'action si on compare la France
aujourd'hui par exemple à la France de
1956 après la crise de Suez la situation
était bien plus difficile donc je pense
qu'il faut relativiser et se dire que il
faut jouer nos atouts
que ça envahit revenir alors votre
grille de lecture du monde d'aujourd'hui
je vais m'arrêter principalement sur
l'Eurasie parce qu'il y a quand même
dans ces pays de la terre marqués par
cette logique continentale la Russie et
la Chine et l'Allemagne pourquoi ces
trois-là
pour une raison assez simple c'est qu'en
fait ce sont les trois totalitarismes du
XXe siècle et que je de mon point de vue
la Russie et la Chine sont en train de
connaître des rechutes en matière de
totalitarisme de manière très différente
et avec des degrés là aussi très très
différents alors que l'Allemagne est
devenu
une certaine manière l'exemple
démocratique au sein de l'Union
européenne donc ça c'est c'est je veux
dire un rappel historique depuis le
depuis le 20e et puis ensuite ce sont
trois pays qui ont une culture
stratégique très basée sur l'assise
continentale c'est très évidemment lié à
leur géographie ça ne signifie pas
qu'ils se sont détournés de la mer au
contraire mais dans le cas de
l'Allemagne historiquement la tentative
de construire une marine à mal tourné
dans le cadre de la Russie c'est aussi
un sujet en fait c'est à dire que la
Russie n'a jamais réussi à être une une
puissance navale de premier plan et le
grand sujet de géopolitique qui nous
occupe c'est l'ambition navale et
maritime de la Chine c'est-à-dire est-ce
que la Chine va réussir son ce qu'on
appelle son basculement thalassocratique
c'est-à-dire son rapport à la mer et ça
c'est une des grandes questions pour les
décennies à venir alors restons un
instant sur la Russie
qui mène la guerre en Ukraine déjà
depuis des années mais de façon bien
plus dure et bien plus violente en
intensité depuis depuis un an tout juste
on a le sentiment que la différence
fondamentale c'est qu'on a compris enfin
nous occidentaux que c'est aussi une
guerre qui nous est menée par Poutine à
nous occidentaux est-ce que c'est
nouveau ça ce discours aussi
occidental de Vladimir Poutine ou c'est
que nous Européens
occidentaux de démocratie nous le voyons
nous l'entendons enfin
je pense c'est plutôt la deuxième la
deuxième option c'est à dire que en
particulier en France et aussi en
Allemagne on a été on a ce que j'appelle
dans le livre le problème russe de la
France c'est-à-dire une lecture en
partie biaisée de la trajectoire de la
Russie que j'explique notamment par le
fait que nous avons eu raison avec la
Russie et l'Allemagne contre
l'intervention anglo-américaine en 2003
et aujourd'hui nous avons beaucoup de
mal à accepter la réalité de la menace
russe qui a été beaucoup plus
précisément décrite par d'autres
capitales européennes avant le 24
février 2022 pourquoi c'est une rue
Sophie historique vous avez une
dimension de russophilie vous avez aussi
un élément qui est la lecture que nous
faisons de l'héritage du général de
Gaulle c'est-à-dire qu'on reste très
focalisé sur 1966 et le retrait du
commandement intégré de l'OTAN on
retient principalement ça alors qu'en
réalité c'est une une politique
étrangère beaucoup plus complexe et qui
est très instrumentalisée par la
diplomatie russe il suffit de suivre les
déclarations à répétition des
diplomatrices sur les plateaux de
chaînes télévision française pour s'en
convaincre et puis aussi
fondamentalement quand on parle en
France de la Russie on pense beaucoup
aux États-Unis et donc le rapport à la
Russie est souvent alimenté par un
anti-américanisme qui traverse beaucoup
de courants politiques ce discours
antioxydantal de
désoxydantalisation connaît un très
grand succès dans le monde
tin il raisonne en Afrique et il
fonctionne en Chine on a du mal à le
comprendre parce que la Russie faisait
partie au XIXe siècle de ces pays qui
ont
coupé de ses droits élémentaires des
Chinois oui la Chine était dans les 8
pays qui ont imposé les traités inégaux
et c'est probablement quelque chose qui
est sous-estimé à Moscou qui est pas du
tout oublier à Pékin quand on parle avec
des pas du tout quand on parle avec des
experts chinois ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est de rappeler que la matrice
idéologique du Parti communiste chinois
est une marque une matrice marxiste les
limites importées du RSS à l'époque et
que ce qui a été le plus étudié par mes
homologues chinois les gens qui font le
même métier que le mien en Chine ce sont
les conditions d'effondrement de l'URSS
est-ce que les chinois ont observé c'est
comment le Parti communiste soviétique
s'est effondré et le 20e congrès du
Parti communiste chinois que nous avons
assisté au mois de octobre 2022 c'est
tout sauf le XXème congrès du parti une
liste chinoise en 1956 qui avait ouvert
la décennalisation au contraire on est
en Chine dans une reprise en main
idéologique extrêmement forte vous dites
que dans ce bloc Chine Russie il y a
aussi l'Asie centrale et l'Inde ça c'est
très important l'Organisation de
coopération de Shanghai que peut
connaissent pourquoi c'est important et
pourquoi l'Inde va selon vous avoir un
rôle déterminant dans cet affrontement
entre l'Occident et les pays qu'on
appelle du Sud global c'est-à-dire ceux
qui se réclament d'un antioxydant au sud
alors l'Inde c'est le grand sujet
géopolitique sur lequel il faut que nous
travaillons tous collectivement de
manière beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
sérieuse pour les raisons vous avez
indiqué c'est-à-dire que l'Inde
condamne la Russie condamne la violation
du droit international pour la réussite
mais ne sanctionne pas condamne
l'invasion
il y a beaucoup de pays qui en fait
choisissent se positionnement
c'est-à-dire que la très grande majorité
des pays ont condamné l'agression mais
ne sanctionne pas pour autant c'est à
dire que le recours à la sanction est en
train de caractériser au fond ce que
Vladimir Poutine appelle l'Occident
collectif de quoi des Non Alignés des
prorus
ensuite vous avez un rapport très très
conflictuel de manière latente entre
l'Inde et la Chine au passage que les
courbes démographiques se sont croisées
c'est-à-dire qu'on a un pied
vieillissant qui est la Chine désormais
et un pays qui est encore très dynamique
sur le plan démographique l'Inde et qui
va devenir la troisième économie
mondiale à horizon 2030 et donc la
dynamique aujourd'hui elle est beaucoup
plus du côté du côté indien même si
évidemment l'avance prise par par la
Chine et tout à fait considérable il y a
un autre facteur très important c'est
que l'Inde reste très tributaire des de
l'approvisionnement militaire de la
Russie et que cette approvisionnement
est aujourd'hui remis en question par
d'autres fournisseurs au premier rang
desquels figurent notamment la France et
ensuite vous avez effectivement un
discours diplomatique de l'Inde qui
consiste à dire c'est ce qu'ils
appellent le aussi alignement le refus
de rentrer dans des alliances militaires
contraignantes et de faire un choix en
réalité de nationalisme assez classique
et effectivement une tentative d'être le
porte-parole de ce qu'on appelle
désormais ce Sud global qui est une
notion que je trouve assez peu
pertinente parce qu'en réalité ce Sud
global et travailler par des dissensions
extrêmement fortes et il est pas du tout
à mon avis aligné et coordonnées le
rasie toujours est borné écrivez-vous
par trois théâtres régionaux ou s'exerce
une confrontation de puissance qui peut
déclencher une déflagration mondiales on
va voir la carte l'Ukraine on en a parlé
mais il y a aussi l'Iran avec la menace
nucléaire et Taïwan vous écrivez Taïwan
la zone géopolitique la plus sensible au
monde
on l'a compris ça nous Français vraiment
nos décideurs en tout cas on peut
l'espérer j'espère oui une partie ne
décideur ont compris ça heureusement
mais si vous voulez je crois ce qu'il
faut ce qui est plus difficile à
comprendre à expliquer ce sont les
effets de bord entre ces trois fronts
c'est à dire que ce qui se passe avec la
guerre du crâne c'est derrière le degré
de convergence sinorus que l'on anticipe
ce qui se passe au Moyen-Orient c'est
pas simplement l'Iran c'est l'évolution
d'Israël vers une trajectoire qui n'est
pas une trajectoire démocratique et
c'est c'est un euphémisme et également
l'effet de bord que ça va avoir
puisqu'on font l'Iran se rapproche de la
Russie et les deux pays deviennent très
intégrés au système énergétique de la
Chine et puis pourquoi
Taïwan nous concerne même si ça nous
semble très loin parce que ça concerne
évidemment le positionnement
international de la Chine et sa rivalité
systémique avec les États-Unis et puis
aussi cette zone là qui nous semble
éloignée elle est décisive regardez
aujourd'hui l'importance prise par la
Corée du Nord fournit des munitions à la
Russie pour se battre en Ukraine ou la
Corée du Sud qui va fournir des armes à
la Pologne dans son effort de réarmement
autrement dit je pense que ce qu'il faut
arriver à faire c'est à relier ces trois
théâtres et à comprendre en réalité que
nous sommes face à un réarmement massif
et de à une guerre dite de droite haute
intensité aujourd'hui en Ukraine il faut
espérer pas au Moyen-Orient mais c'est
probable et et être très attentif à ce
qui se passe à Taïwan
puisse supporter 3 terrains de
déflagration potentielle
d'accélération de la contrainte
environnementale
en jeu globale qui s'enchevêtent aux
enjeux politiques dont on a parlé la
crise climatique c'est très important
dans votre livre vous allez même jusqu'à
parler d'une écologie de guerre
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça l'écologie
de guerre si vous voulez c'est de dire
que la grande la grande rupture
provoquée par la guerre d'Ukraine c'est
l'arrêt de la relation énergétique entre
la l'Union européenne et la qui s'est
construite sur plusieurs décennies c'est
très difficile à encaisser pour les
Européens parce que ça génère
l'inflation que nous connaissons c'est
un des éléments qui génère l'inflation
que que nous connaissons mais à certains
égards si l'Union européenne parvient à
passer ses vagues et c'est ainsi très
important au fond elle est bien orientée
pour essayer de défiler son appareil
productif et d'aller beaucoup plus vite
faire la décarbonation mais il faut
avantage comparatif saisir il faut
l'espérer mais c'est très difficile
parce que c'est très onéreux et on le
fait avec des Européens qui ne sont pas
alignés en particulier franco-allemand
sur le type de politique énergétique à
adopter c'est passionnant on aurait pu
continuer longtemps
vous parlez aussi des États-Unis
également est-ce qu'on va vers un
affrontement voilà des démocraties
contre les puissions se totalitaires
l'idée ce livre les ambitions inavouées
pour le comprendre ce que prépare les
grandes puissantes du point de vue de
nos adversaires certains diront de nos
ennemis c'est chez thaï en Dieu merci et
de nos alliés absolument vous parler
d'autres pays comme le Royaume-Uni
notamment ou les États-Unis Thomas
Gomart vous restez avec nous ça y est
c'est l'heure des affranchis vous allez
voir ils vont vous faire réagir leur
parti pris tout de suite on vous
accueille les affranchis
bonsoir
bonsoir à vous de Richard Richard Verly
qui revient de Berlin ça va vous
intéresser Thomas Goma et qui va nous
parler au fond de la manière dont on est
vue ou trop reins et dont cette grogne
sociale est regardée de la bas et puis
Fanny Fanny bonsoir des informés de
France Info du brief écho le matin sur
les ondes qui revient sur le panier à
flason annoncé à Bercy mais on va
commencer avec une histoire je suis sur
elle va vous passionner de bras
d'honneur à l'Assemblée c'est Bourbon
Express ce soir racontez par Elsa dans
un gala bonsoir Elsa oui bonsoir je vais
vous parler d'un bras d'honneur c'est
pas au sens figuré c'est au sens propre
un bras d'honneur même deux fait par le
garde des sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti
dans l'hémicycle oui oui vous avez bien
entendu ça s'est passé tout à l'heure
c'était à peu près 17h30 les députés
examinaient une proposition de loi
présentée par la présidente du groupe
renaissance pour rendre inéligible les
auteurs de violences conjugales et
intrafamiliales donc les députés se
succèdent à la tribune pour parler il y
a le garde vaisseau qui est présent
évidemment le président du groupe les
républicains Olivier marlex va prendre
la parole puis c'est au tour d'une
députée modem à ce moment là il y a un
peu de brouha dans l'hémicycle on
comprend pas forcément pourquoi et un
député va prendre la parole et dire cela
pendant que notre président de groupe là
aussi descendait de la tribune le Garde
des Sceaux a fait un bras d'honneur
c'est quelque chose d'assez un
qualifiable et oui il accuse le garde
des sauts d'avoir fait un bras d'honneur
je vous avoue quand on a entendu ça nous
à la rédaction on en a pas cru nos
oreilles sauf que et bien Éric
Dupond-Moretti il se lève et il confirme
il y a pas un brin d'honneur il y en a
deux mais accompagné de parole à chaque
fois qui sont
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre ou pas de quoi vous
parlez exactement vous avez fait deux
bras d'honneur c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de dire à l'Assemblée
alors oui je vous demande effectivement
de préciser vos propos parce que si
c'est le cas ça n'est absolument pas
admissible alors je vous laisse finir
vos propos vous n'avez pas à faire des
bras d'honneur dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit Madame j'ai dit Madame bras
d'honneur à la présomption d'innocence
je l'ai dit de voir
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez la présidente de sens n'en
revient pas
et consterné en fait le garde des sceaux
il explique qu'il n'a pas adressé ce
geste au président de des républicains
mais qu'en fait il disait dénoncer et
bien ça qu'il avait fait un bras
d'honneur à la présomption d'innocence
parce que Olivier Marleix dans son
argumentaire il s'était fait un malin
plaisir à rappeler un peu les affaires
judiciaires qui touchent la majorité et
il avait grattignié le garde des sceaux
oui mise en examen dont celle du
secrétaire général de la présidence de
la République excusez du peu et pardon
monsieur le garde celle du garde des
sceaux accusé l'un et l'autre de prise
légale d'intérêt
voilà donc pourquoi garder souffle a
décidé de faire des bras d'honneur alors
évidemment la séance a été suspendue et
à la reprise et bien de garder ça il a
repris la parole et il se lance un
premier temps il s'est justifié son
geste je vous l'ai dit n'était pas
dirigé contre le député Marley mais
c'était justement pour critiquer cette
attaque à la présomption d'innocence
alors des excuses des justifications qui
n'étaient absolument pas des excuses qui
n'ont pas du tout convenu au président
des républicains qui en a demandé des
excuses et en bonne et due forme
je pense que faire un bras d'honneur
pour un membre du gouvernement à deux
pardon de selon votre aveu de la part
d'un membre du gouvernement a un membre
de la représentation nationale me paraît
extrêmement peu extrêmement peu
exemplaire et donc enfin voilà et je
pense que votre attitude monsieur le
garde des sceaux je comprends que vous
avez pu fréquenter beaucoup de de voyous
dans votre carrière professionnelle et
je comprends que ça ait pu à un moment
d'éteindre un peu sur votre comportement
mais c'est plus qui n'approprier et ça
exige des excuses non pas pour moi mais
à l'égard de la représentation nationale
toutes les oppositions demandent des
excuses au ministre pas privés Mathilde
panot par exemple la chef de fil des
ansoumis d'habitude elle est plutôt du
côté de ceux à qui on demande de
s'excuser donc elle s'est pas privée de
faire la leçon au gouvernement
je dois dire que c'est quand même
particulièrement savoureux de voir que
vous refusez le minimum c'est-à-dire de
vous excuser auprès de Monsieur Marleix
et de la représentation nationale pour
ce même qui nous donne constamment des
leçons de maintien et qui nous
expliquent sans cesse qu'ils sont les
Arbites des élégances et qui ne sont pas
capables de s'excuser lorsqu'ils font de
tels gestes
nouvelle suspension de séance et au
retour et bien il y a un changement de
stratégie de Lex avocat écoutez je suis
je le dis à toutes les représentations
nationales
profondément affectée
par ce moment que je suis
[Musique]
amené à vivre je redis ici
avec beaucoup de force que
je n'ai pas voulu viser le président
Marleix mais si mon geste a été mal
interprété je lui présente mes excuses
ainsi qu'à toute la présentation
nationale
bon est-ce que les débats ont pu
reprendre après alors ils ont repris
mais on vient de la prendre la
proposition de loi a été rejetée c'est
une grande surprise parce que dans la
majorité au groupe Renaissance même si
on savait que notamment le modèle
horizon était pas très allant et qu'il y
avait beaucoup de critiques on pensait
très certainement de cette proposition
de loi a été allée être adoptée c'est
donc un revers politique pour la
majorité c'est aussi très compliqué on
peut dire que le garde des sceaux il
n'aurait jamais dû dire ça surtout
contre Olivier marlex vous savez c'est
celui qui avec ses députés LR ils
détiennent la clé de la réforme des
retraites et peut-être pas le moment
d'énerver tout le monde se tient un peu
merci beaucoup Elsa on enchaîne et
rapidement s'il vous plaît Richard vous
revenez de Berlin et à votre grande
surprise vous avez trouvé des Allemands
indulgents avec notre climat social oui
alors je sais pas si on va leur montrer
ces images aux Allemands parce que ça
pourrait les faire réagir effectivement
j'étais à Berlin la semaine dernière et
je m'attendais à recevoir à la figure
une volée de chiffres et de contraintes
économiques or ce n’a pas été le cas les
responsables politiques et les
observateurs que j'ai rencontrés bien
ils ne mangent pas de ce pas là
aujourd'hui ils sont
beaucoup de gens pour la France qu'ils
estiment être toujours leur
indispensable partenaire alors ils
savent que ce n'est pas facile vous
souvenez Myriam on en avait parlé sur ce
plateau au moment de l'anniversaire du
traité franco-allemand mais pas question
outre-rein de sermonner Paris de
sermonner les Français leur est plutôt à
l'attentisme au pragmatisme volontarisme
la France il le savent a besoin de crise
pour avancer à legood c'est comme ça on
est habitué alors j'ai quand même reposé
les questions qui fâchent sur l'Ukraine
sur la Russie sur le déficit public sur
la dette qui font partie de l'équation
en tout cas c'est ce que je croyais de
la réforme des retraites alors j'ai
mieux compris cette indulgence allemande
parce que les Allemands ils ont des
remords en ce moment d'abord il dépense
beaucoup à leur échelle il dépense aussi
maintenant pour la modernisation de leur
armée ce qui leur fait comprendre que la
défense ça coûte cher et qu'il s'en
était longtemps abstenu et puis il
regarde vers la Pologne ils arrêtent pas
de dire que la France doit comprendre
que la Pologne est un nouveau géant
européen mais ils n'ont pas tout à fait
confiance dans les Polonais et donc ils
préfèrent pour l'instant plutôt ménager
les Français donc ça ressemble à un
vieux couple habitué
effectivement mais à une différence
c'est que les Allemands aujourd'hui ils
ont un système politique qui n'est pas
dysfonctionnel alors le chancelier
scholls il a une coalition compliquée on
le sait il a un parti social-démocrate
qui n'est pas facile à gérer parce qu'il
est plutôt pacifiste mais les Allemands
ils l'ont pris le tournant de ce qu'on
appelle la zeitan 22 le changement
d'époque donc le risque pour Paris n'est
pas tellement de voir Berlin dire non
mais simplement de voir l'Allemagne
s'éloigner prendre les tournants plus
vite que la France il n'y a pas un
affrontement de modèles ou une
concurrence de solutions entre la France
et l'Allemagne il y a une course de
vitesse pour s'adapter à la nouvelle
donne européenne et mondiale alors je
sais qu'en France certains répondront
sans doute en citant la fontaine rien ne
sert de courir il faut partir à point et
voilà qui résonne avec votre livre on
n'a pas le temps de vous faire réagir
mais je renvoie à votre livre parce que
cette question du couple franco-allemand
était évoquée Fanny hausse des prix
oblige on attendait depuis des semaines
maintenant ce fameux panier alimentaire
panier inflation promis par le
gouvernement alors en fait ce seront
plusieurs paniers qui pour la plupart
exister déjà et oui en fait il va pas y
avoir de grands changements et les
consommateurs risquent d'être déçus
l'idée de ce panier anti-inflation
c'était de sélectionner un certain
nombre de produits essentiels pour une
famille pour éviter que des ménages
modestes avec enfants notamment soit
privé d'un certain nombre de denrées de
première nécessités et donc de maintenir
ses prix Les prix de ces produits a pris
coûtant au plus bas possible bon en
réalité chaque enseigne avait fait son
panier inflation en tout cas sa liste de
produits à prix coûtant bien avant que
le gouvernement hier nous fasse une
grande réunion et c'est vrai que
Carrefour inter-marché avait mis en
place ces dispositifs mais Michel
Édouard Leclerc lui hier il a dit je ne
veux pas être je ne vais rien faire je
ne fais pas de panier inflation parce
que moi je lutte tout le temps contre
les prix donc il ne voulait pas
participer à l'opération de
communication du gouvernement mais c'est
vraiment de la com vous pensez un petit
peu parce qu'on a vu Bruno Le Maire
entouré hier des dirigeants de ces
grandes enseignes et communiquer sur le
fait qu'il y avait eu un accord qui
avait été trouvé en réalité ils
demandent il fait la pression sur les
distributeurs pour qu'ils rogne un petit
peu leur marge alors ces lois de la part
d'un ministre de l'économie à un moment
où l'inflation expose mais c'est vrai
que par rapport à la promesse initiale
du gouvernement un panier universel
unique pour toutes les enseignes qui
seraient mis en place on en est très
loin et puis il y a un petit souci c'est
qu'en fait dans ces produits chacun fait
bien comme il veut chaque enseigne a
décidé de mettre un certain nombre de
produits ce qu'on appelle les marques
distributeurs c'est à dire que c'est ces
produits à elle et puis il y a un petit
souci que relève notamment nos amis de
l'UFC Que Choisir qui disent que ces
produits ne sont pas tous dans les
produits sélectionnés par les enseignes
ils sont pas tous de très bonnes
qualités nutritionnelles il y a la
question derrière de la qualité des
produits alors merci avait parlé d'un
chèque alimentaire c'est un peu
l'arlésienne où on en est là dessus
alors c'est toujours l'arlésienne merci
on parle toujours nous promet qu'il avec
des expérimentations les départements
les départements Bercy est pas très
allant sur ce sur cette promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron promesse
présidentielle mais elle devrait arriver
bref en fait on voit que ce soit avec le
panier entier inflation ou le chèque ou
le chèque alimentation que c'est très
très difficile aujourd'hui de vouloir
dans une économie de marché
réguler les prix ce qui régule les prix
c'est l'offre la demande la concurrence
et pour l'instant surtout avec des
distributeurs et des producteurs qui
sont en ce moment à couteau Thierry
merci beaucoup Fanny Gauchet économie
ouverte là aussi ça fait écho à votre
livre les ambitions inavouées Thomas
gaumart merci d'être venu sur le plateau
LCP de date qui viennent de nous
parvenir en direct pendant cette
émission 11 mars et 15 mars pour les
nouvelles journées d'action à l'appel de
l'Inter syndical intercer syndicale qui
demande à être reçu au plus vite au
sommet de l'État par le Président de la
République très belle soirée
documentaire à demain journée spéciale 8
mars avec Yaël brode Pivet dans votre
fauteuil Thomas Gomar qui sera notre
grand témoin à la présidente de
l'Assemblée très belle soirée à vous
[Musique]